der erste bundesgesundheitsminister den
auch das netz geklettert quali vom volk
direkt gewählt der durch die talkshows
geht ist wie kein zweiter politiker
allein über 40 mal in diesem jahr der
mann der in den letzten monaten manches
früher und besser wusste muss jetzt
zeigen ob er es auch besser kann und in
dem olaf scholz dann deshalb auch
irgendwie gar nicht mehr vorbei kamen er
wird es aber kann er es auch
[Applaus]
unser neuer bundesgesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach gleich die ersten tage
im amt hatten es echt in sich für king
karl er macht inventur im ministerium
und findet anscheinend zu wenig
impfstoff ein paar seiner prognosen
fallen ihnen jetzt schon auf die füße
und er ist immer noch ständig im
fernsehen dabei hatte er sich doch
vorgenommen das wird etwas weniger
werden seit seiner amtsübernahme war
karl lauterbach schon wieder bei anne
will maybrit illner und bei markus lanz
bisschen wie so ein raucher der sich
kurz vorm aufhören erst noch mal eine
stange kaufen geht ich bin sicher dass
das amt die in so fordern wird dass wir
nicht so häufig mehr auf dem schirm
sehen während in der vergangenheit das
mag man bedauern manche würden das
begrüßen und hier 78 prozent der
deutschen sagen er wird seine sache gut
machen die erwartungen an lauterbach
sind schon mal viel größer als an den
neuen finanzminister oder an die neue
außenministerin ich glaube trotzdem es
könnte schwer werden für ihn aus drei
gründen zum ersten wird karl lauterbach
jetzt von einigen seiner eigenen
aussagen eingeholt
[Musik]
eine booster impfung für alle wäre jetzt
auf keinen fall sinnvoll wir haben zum
einen keinen medizinischen grund den
booster für alle jetzt anzubieten weil
die impfung für die unter 65 70 jährige
noch wirksam ist sehr gut wirksam ist
kein booster notwendig sagt lauterbach
und dann die kehrtwende
nur 17 tage später es ist klar seit ein
paar monaten dass wir halt jeden
erwachsenen boostern ist halt ein paar
monaten ein paar monaten ist das klar
das ist klar und das haben wir so
spezialisten auch also relativ früh also
eine klassische 180 grad wende die
kannst du vielleicht als experte mal
hinlegen da merkte im zweifel gar keiner
versendet sich aber als minister könnte
dir sowas echt auf die füße fallen wenn
du erst sagt buß dann brauchen wir nicht
und dann sagst du es dann ganz wichtig
jetzt und dann wird derselbe karl
lauterbach der also noch vor wochen
sagte buß dann für alle brauchen wir
nicht der wird jetzt seinem vorgänger
jens spahn vor dass der nicht genügend
impfstoff für die große poster kampagne
fürs erste quartal gestellt habe in der
tat also wir haben zu wenig impfstoff
und das hat viele überrascht in der
inventur mich auch die union schießt
natürlich zurück das sei ein
durchsichtiges politisches manöver von
karl lauterbach und natürlich habe ich
jens spahn genügend impfstoff bestellt
wie sauer die sind kann man gut sehen an
diesem brief den der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der cdu
geschrieben hat tino sorge und er
schreibt karl lauterbach ruft feuer um
dann feuerwehr zu spielen obwohl er weiß
dass es gar nicht brennt soll kein
vorwurf sein mein amtsvorgänger sagt
lauterbach jetzt immer aber der vorwurf
ist natürlich jetzt in der welt und was
stimmt das können wir journalisten auch
nicht wirklich nachprüfen weil wir alle
nicht in die bücher schauen können wir
können nicht sehen was ist wirklich
geliefert worden ein impfstoff was liegt
womöglich noch in irgendwelchen praxen
rum was ist vielleicht weggeschmissen
worden weil es überlagert worden ist und
so bleibt dieses ganze thema ein
bisschen eine blackbox der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der union
sagt wir haben ungefähr 10 millionen
biontech wir haben noch 40 millionen
moderner das sind die dosen die wir
haben was sind ihre zahlen also zunächst
mal ich wünschte die zahlen die union
vor trägt während richtig fakt ist
lauterbachs zahlen widersprechen zum
teil einer liefert tabelle die sein
eigenes ministerium veröffentlicht hat
fakt ist auch lauterbach bestellt mit
großem tam impfstoff nach und sorgt
dafür dass ist jeder mitkriegt
[Musik]
wofür ihn die einen schätzen nämlich
seine große expertise hassen ihn die
anderen lauterbach galt vielen immer
auch als schwarzmaler in der korona
krise als panikmacher seine strengen
lockdown rufe kam in der wirtschaft zum
beispiel nie besonders gut an und auch
in der spd haben ihn ganz viele für eine
pessimistische nervensäge gehalten wenn
er zum beispiel drohte corona ist auch
in vier jahren nicht vorbei ihm selber
war das immer egal auch wenn es mal
anders kann als es selber vorhergesagt
hatte karl lauterbach warnt mitte april
für die nächsten sechs wochen vor über
10.000 toten erbt panikmache die er
heute bereut man das buch nicht denn die
warnungen beschreiben was passiert
werden wir nicht gegensteuern das ist es
ganz klassisch schicksal eines vorbeuge
mediziners dass prävention spa dogs
darüber spricht karl lauterbach immer
gerne aber jetzt muss er ganz schnell
umschalten vom vorbeuge mediziner vom
maler vom dienst der oft wenn auch nicht
immer recht hatte hinzu macher vom
wissenschaftler der jede nacht zehn
studien inhaliert hat hin zum exekutiven
manager der ein ministerium mit 750
leuten führen muss aber lauterbach
findet so scheint es mir noch gar nicht
so richtig raus aus diesem alten modus
und waren zum beispiel jetzt mitten in
der vierten welle vor einer massiven
fünfte welle und hier am tag seiner
amtsübernahme da waren ja im heute
journal im zdf vor der gefährlichkeit
von omikron gerade für kinder wir müssen
davon ausgehen dass also gerade die
uniko und variante für kinder besonders
bedrohlich ist dass das ist leider so
dass die omikron variante sich nicht nur
schneller verbreitet sondern leider auch
kinder stärker befällt und somit auch zu
mir krankenhauseinweisungen führen wird
ich habe mich ja damals schon gefragt
wie kann er das wissen ich meine anfang
dezember da wussten wird auch noch
praktisch nichts über die omikron
variante warum wartet lauterbach nicht
ab warum legt er sich fest für kinder
besonders bedrohlich und jetzt heißt es
auch mit omikron haben kinder
überwiegend milde symptome kein grund
zur panik
auch das ist sicher noch keine
endgültige erkenntnis weltweit versuchen
wissenschaftler herauszufinden wie sich
omikron tatsächlich auswirken können
aber vom bundesgesundheitsminister
erwarte ich keine schnellschüsse keine
warnungen auf verdacht keine mutmaßungen
sondern fundierte informationen und
daraus dann abgeleitete strategien für
die pandemie bekämpfung auch olaf scholz
weiß natürlich um diese schwäche von
karl lauterbach und hat ihm offenbar zum
amtsantritt das versprechen abgenommen
ein bisschen optimismus zu verbreiten
aller angela merkel was soll ich sagen
er hat es versucht weil soll ja nicht
sagen i schaffen dass
das soll man ja nicht sagen aber wenn
ich wenn ich ehrlich wenn nicht ganz
wenn ich nicht ganz ehrlich sagen soll
ich glaube nicht nur sondern ich weiß
dass wir das schaffen werden
[Musik]
bisher war karl lauterbach ein echter
one man show für uns journalisten musste
man sich das in etwa immer so vorstellen
da nimmt die panini irgendeine wendung
dann russo karl lauterbach auf dem handy
an und sagt herr lauterbach würden sie
uns dazu eine einschätzung geben und
dann sagte er klar in 30 minuten in köln
auf dem bahnhofsvorplatz schicken sie
mir ein kamerateam und so kam es dass
karl lauterbach quasi in den letzten
zwei jahren täglich in den nachrichten
zu sehen war lauterbach brauchte keine
pressestelle der brauchte nur sein handy
und twitter dort folgen ihm über 700.000
menschen mehr als doppelt so viele wie
olaf scholz und lauterbach twittert bis
heute immer selbst das machen nur wenige
politiker aber das ist eben auch ein
zeitfresser gerade für einen minister
und wahrscheinlich ein albtraum für jede
pressestelle weil man nie weiß welches
feuer der chef im internet gleich
widerlegt und es gibt
kommunikationsprofis die raten deshalb
das muster reduzieren die leute im land
von einem gesundheitsminister grad
erwarten dass ein großteil seiner zeit
nicht in sozialen medien verbringt
sondern sich den großen aufgaben und
herausforderungen widmet da besteht die
gefahr einer meinung nach das er
falschen eindruck erweckt wenn er
sozusagen hochfrequent kommuniziert ich
glaube es eine andere autorität die
jetzt in seine rolle hat ja aber andere
sagen genau das hat ihn ins amt gespült
lauterbach ist der pandemie erklärer er
ist authentisch erst nahbar stimmt sagt
henne auch aber jetzt ist er eben
minister und muss theoretisch jeden tag
den fakten check bestehen er muss jetzt
vor allem eben aber auch leute erreichen
die er bisher nicht so erreicht hat die
kunst ist es ja nicht 70 prozent der
leute die geimpft sind davon zu
überzeugen sich nochmal zu ostern das
werden die tun so wie der impfstoff da
ist sondern das problem ist ja wie er
selbst sagt die leute zu erreichen die
dort zwei film aber klar ein lauter
machen wird sich auch als
bundesgesundheitsminister nicht völlig
neu erfinden das bleibt jetzt erst mal
ein experiment nämlich wie passen
politik und wissenschaft zusammen weil
sich ein gutes zeichen finde ist dass
karl lauterbach ja gerade den
expertenrat für olaf scholz neu
zusammengesetzt hat und da sind jetzt
eben nicht mehr nur leute wie christian
drosten drin die lauterbach naturgemäß
nahe stehen die sind beide eher auf der
vorsichtigen seite sondern da sind jetzt
auch leute drin neu wie hendrik strikt
der erfahrungsgemäß nicht immer einer
meinung war mit karl lauterbach und hat
ihn trotzdem da rein geholt und das
zeigt für mich dass karl lauterbach
offen ist für andere ansichten und
womöglich auch mal für andere ansätze in
der pandemie bekämpft
[Musik]
karl lauterbach ist ganz klar ein
krisengewinner der wäre mit ziemlicher
sicherheit niemals in dieses amt
gekommen wenn es corona nie gegeben
hätte aber die frage die sich stellt ist
passt das auch noch zusammen wenn die
pandemie mal vorbei ist wenn sich der
bundesgesundheitsminister nämlich auch
wieder um das brot und butter geschäft
kümmern muss um die zukunft nicht nur
der pflegeberufe sondern auch der
hebamme oder der physiotherapeuten um
das krankenhaus management um die
zukunft der privaten krankenversicherung
wenn er also quasi das komplette
gesundheitssystem umkrempeln muss wenn
man das da lautet aber auch diese
einfachen probleme sind jetzt ihre
probleme ja da kann man grandios
scheitern oder alles gewinnen was meint
ihr denn kann karl krise und das danach
auch schreibt uns gerne in die
kommentare
und ansonsten abonniert uns liegt uns
und schaut gerne auch die anderen tollen
inside politics videos übrigens das
willkommensgeschenk des
gesundheitsministeriums für karl
lauterbach war ein nussknacker erlaube
mir mal
dafür das bestmögliche instrument mit
auf den weg zu geben
nämlich einen nussknacker aus deutscher
produktion
und ich sage ihnen ich habe lange
gesucht ich habe die härtesten und
größten müsse in ganz berlin dazu
ausgesucht in diesem sinne knick knack